[Musique]
le musée léon dierx inaugure sa nouvelle
exposition temporaire baptisée les eaux
du nil
le photographe morgan fâche expose ses
clichés qui sont la restitution d'une
résidence d'artiste patrimoine et
création qui aura duré six mois le temps
pour ce photographe d'aller à la
rencontre des territoires reculés de la
réunion et de sa population
c'est un peu un peu la présentation de
ce projet quoi c'est d'aller à la
rencontre sans vraiment savoir où je
vais et de rencontrer des gens qui
kiffent qui font l'histoire de laure de
leur village leur l'histoire des de leur
commune des eaux
et pourtant qui sont peut-être aussi
dans leur commune des anonymes mais qui
en même temps en fait on construit un
patrimoine qui qu'ils enlevaient leur
identité quoi et si moi non pas par
exemple c'est quelqu'un qui connaît son
histoire qui a grandi à grand coude
ses paysages et ses portraits réalisés
en argentique montre les facettes et les
visages des eaux de l'île cette série
d'image vient compléter dans cette
exposition un ensemble de photographies
originales datant des années 50 et 60
une perspective entre le passé et le
présent
ces documents anciens présente en fait
une image un peu une idée qu une vision
à un temps donné d'une réunion des
années 50-60 d'une vision des eaux qui
correspond à un temps donné et c'est
intéressant de montrer justement ce
parallèle est cependant et ce dialogue
comment on peut instaurer un dialogue
finalement entre cette vision ancienne
il ya 50
l'entente est une vision aujourd'hui
faite par un photographe
en 2019 qui a décidé de témoigner en
fait de co2 lille avec son regard qui
t'a regard d'un jeune contemporain sur
les autres les curieux auront jusqu'au 5
avril prochain pour découvrir cette
exposition et voyager dans le coeur des
hauts de la réunion
[Musique]